i had the opportunity to visit
afghanistan twice
but i recognize that there are others
across this house whose experience is
more recent more vivid more practical
longer and broader than mine
but when i was there i was struck by the
commitment and dedication of our armed
forces serving there and of other
british personnel
all were doing what they could to give
hope to the people of afghanistan
people who thanks to our presence were
able to enjoy freedoms they have been
denied under the taliban
twenty years on
457 british military personnel have died
in afghanistan and many more have
suffered life-changing injuries
yes many girls have been educated
because of british aid
but it is not just that the freedoms
once enjoyed will now be taken away
but there are many many afghans not just
those who worked with british forces who
are now in fear of their lives
it is right that we should open up a
refugee scheme
but we must make it absolutely certain
that it is accessible to all those who
need it
now of course the nato presence was
always going
to end at some point in time
but the withdrawal when it came was due
to be orderly planned
and on the basis of conditions
it has been none of these
what has been most shocking
has been the chaos and the speed of the
takeover by the taliban
in july of this year both president
biden and my right honourable friend the
prime minister
indicated that they did not think that
the taliban was ready or able to take
over control of the country
was our intelligence really so poor
was our understanding of the afghan
government so weak was our knowledge of
the position on the ground so inadequate
or did we really believe this
or did we just feel that we had to
follow the united states and hope that
on a wing and a prayer it would be all
right on the night
because the reality is if i may just
make this point the reality is
that as long as this a time limit was
given and dates were given for
withdrawal
all the taliban had to do
was to ensure there were sufficient
problems for the afghan government not
to be able to have full control of the
country and then just sit and wait
would my right honourable friend agree
that president biden decided
unilaterally to withdraw without
agreeing and negotiating a plan with
either the afghan government or the nato
allies and the response of the uk
government in the circumstances has been
fast purposeful and extremely extremely
well guided to protecting the interests
of uk citizens
[Applause]
[Music]
i just say to my right honourable friend
what president biden has done is upheld
a decision that was made by president
trump
it was a unilateral decision of
president trump to do a deal with the
taliban that has led to this withdrawal
and of course what we've seen from the
scenes in afghanistan is that it hasn't
been all right on the night as i say
there are many in afghanistan who fear
not just that their lives will be
irrevocably changed for the worse but
who fear for their lives
numbered among them will be women
women who embrace freedom embrace the
right to education to work and to
participate in the political process
my right honourable friend the prime
minister was right to make the education
of girls a key aim of his administration
but in afghanistan that will now be
swept away
those girls who have been educated will
have no opportunity to use that
education
the taliban proclaimed that women will
be allowed to work and girls will be
allowed to go to school but this will be
under islamic law or rather under their
interpretation of islamic law
if i mention and we have seen before
what that means for the lives of women
and girls
i'm very grateful my right honourable
friend give give away on that point some
of the women who show most courage are
the 250 women who serve as judges are
under the attempt that was made to
impose a decent honest legal system on
gap in afghanistan they are particularly
feared as being targets the bar council
law society have asked the government to
particularly take a cognizance of the
particular risk that they run will she
support the quarter for them to be given
particular priority in being brought to
safety because they put their lives on
their line for their fellow women and
for their whole country yeah yeah
very important point as has been said
there are many groups in afghanistan who
have actually put their lives on the
line to to support the afghan government
to support democracy to support justice
in afghanistan and it is right that we
should do everything that we can to
support them in their time of need
but as we know under the i may just make
a further point about women and girls as
we know under the taliban regime sadly
the life of women and girls will not be
the same they will not have the rights
what we believe they should have and
they will not have the freedoms that
they should have i'll be waiting later
okay there are already reports from
sources in kabul that the taliban is
executing collaborators and homosexuals
it does she agree with me that
complacency is absolutely misplaced and
what does she suggest should we do to
protect those people who need to get out
can i say to the honourable lady the
government is doing much to protect
people in trying to ensure that it is
possible for people to be able to access
uh ways of leaving afghanistan
now i think a point was made earlier
about the issue of not just expecting
people to get to kabul and i hope that
this is something that the government
will be able to look into and be able to
take up presumably
furthermore apart from the impact on
people's lives in terms of women and
girls we do see potential humanitarian
crisis
at least in some parts of afghanistan
now of course we cut our international
aid budget but i'm pleased that the
foreign secretary has told me that more
funding is going to be made available to
deal with this with this crisis
but it isn't just about the impact of
the people on afghanistan that must
concern us we must be deeply concerned
about the possible impact here in the uk
the aim of our involvement in
afghanistan was to ensure that it could
not be used as a haven for terrorists
terrorists who could train plot and
encourage and tax here in the uk you
should keep wearing them okay if i'm
just
al qaeda has not gone away
daesh may have lost their ground in
syria but these terrorist groups remain
and they have spurned spawned others
we will not defeat them until we have
defeated the ideology which feeds their
extremism
for giving way is she concerned i mean
one of the most concerning things that's
happening is that several half thousand
um
al-qaeda operatives have been freed from
background prison from kabul prison from
kandahar does she think does she cons is
she concerned these people are going to
go back to their own bold ways or do we
hope that they're somehow going to go
into retirement because it seems to me
that we are going to restart the new
round of international terrorism
my my honourable friend has actually
anticipated point i was exactly about to
make which is the taliban of course have
said that they will not allow
afghanistan to become a haven for
terrorists again uh yesterday in the
press conference they said they would
not allow anything to happen in
afghanistan which led to attacks
elsewhere across the world but the their
actions must be what we look at not
their words and their action has as my
honourable friend has just pointed out
being to release thousands of high-value
taliban al-qaeda and daesh fighters so
that action is completely different from
their words and i think it is absolutely
essential for us
to recognize that the probability that
afghanistan will once again become a
breeding ground for the terrorists who
seek to destroy our way of life
thank you for giving way
i hope to hear from the prime minister
and didn't
the reasons that we went into
afghanistan in 2002 remain valid today
if the actions that have been taken in
recent weeks render a military solution
to that problem impossible
then we have to have a non-military
solution what does she see that
non-military solution as being
it's the right honourable gentleman i'm
going to make a reference later on to
this issue i think that it is he's
absolutely right that the question of a
military solution has not been there
actually for some time because our
combat mission ended some years ago but
what we have been doing is trying to
provide the support to enable a
democratic government to actually take
take
proper control of that country i'd be
happy to talk to the right honourable
gentleman at some time about my views
but actually i think that the idea of
imposing western trying to impose just a
western example of democracy actually in
a country which is geographically
difficult and which relies a lot on on
regional uh government is act possibly
was a route that we should have
reconsidered when we were going down
that route but i will not go down that
to that road any longer
despite his temptations but there was
another
i would think
about the time for bike venture i did
suggest it was seven minutes with no
heading to 10. i didn't put the time
limit on but i'm going to have to do
after this
speaker i'm very grateful for for uh
your generosity to me for the uk there
was another important element of our
work in afghanistan that was stopping
the drugs from coming into the united
kingdom sadly that has not been as
successful as we would have liked it to
have been but we did uh support a drug
crime specific criminal justice system
in afghanistan i assume that is now
going to come to a complete end so once
again this is another area where
withdrawal is not just about afghanistan
it has an impact on the streets of the
uk but what must also be of key concern
to us is the message this sends around
the world to those who would do the west
ham
the message it sends about our
capabilities and most important about
our willingness to defend our values
what does it say about us as a country
what does it say about nato if we are
entirely dependent on a unilateral
decision taken by the united
states we all understand the importance
of american support
but despite the comments from my right
honourable friend earlier i do find it
incomprehensible and worrying that the
united kingdom was not able to bring
together not a military solution but an
alternative alliance of countries to
continue to provide the support
necessary to sustain a government in
afghanistan
surely one outcome of this must be a
reassessment of how nato operates nato
is the bedrock of european security but
russia will not be blind to the
implications of this withdrawal decision
and the manner in which it has been
taken
neither will china and others have
failed to notice the implications
because in recent years the west has
appeared to be less willing to defend
its values this cannot continue because
if it does it will embolden those who do
not share those values and wish to
impose their way of life on others
i'm afraid i think this has been a major
setback for british foreign policy
we boast about global britain but where
is global britain on the streets of
kabul
a successful foreign policy strategy
will be judged by our deeds not by our
words
and i finally just say this
all of our military personnel
all who served in afghanistan should
hold their heads high
and be proud
of what they achieved in that country
over 20 years
of the change of life they brought to
the people of afghanistan and the safety
they brought here to the uk
the politicians sent them there
the politicians decided to withdraw
the politicians must be responsible for
the consequences